i can't do this anymore
yeah i tried to do separation
in the same room
things haven't done any good
i guess but because you you haven't
respect my space
i know i haven't respected your space
yeah and you you try to
be a little bit you know like very
pursue me i know like people pursue me i
know like people try to you know chase
me i don't like dusting
and you know that i don't like to be
chased
and for real i the only the only reason
that i want to talk to you because right
now
because i'm filming like for real i want
to get out of the house
i want my divorce
like i'm sorry
i don't want to go to the point but
i can
i can continue with this
pedro he can't even look straight in my
eyes and he tells me that he wants a
divorce
i wonder what that is about a person
when they can't look at you straight in
the eyes
i wonder what that is
why are you guilty of something
i didn't expect for you to say that you
wanted a divorce for me
i really just wanted to know if
you valued this marriage and were
willing to work on it and the answer is
no
so there's nothing more we need to
discuss
[Music]
all the love is gone it's nothing it's
nothing left there man
it's very
you know it's like jesus
you know you feel a pain in your chest
you know you you feel these things your
chest that you say like
god damn it
[Music]
you